she has to make sound effects throughout
the whole
whole round
slash
point i'm gonna get ready to give it to
you [ __ ]
pew pew pew
what's up everybody i am zachy and i'm
gerald and we're back for another video
in fact we're gonna do something a
little bit different aren't we gerald
yes in the spirit of giving we'll be
giving out a lot of cash prizes not
request prices but donations to a lot of
streamers on the twitch channels we'll
be checking out tonight and it's all
part of the season of giving you know
that it's not easy being a streamer in
fact i myself have tried streaming and i
can tell it's it's a lot of hard work
it's super hard work man the more things
they need to talk and to keep people
entertained man those people who are
streaming on single digits they need a
bit of help coach you also mentioned
prices so the folks at logitech has been
very generous and we're gonna be giving
out what's that you're holding we've got
the shim cam for creators and we've got
the blue yeti x very excellent gear for
anyone who's looking to stream right so
without further ado let's check out some
streamers
oh our friend measure me hello hello
geek culture how's it going welcome to
stream you guys want to see something
really cool yes yes
monitor not working he has a heart rate
monitor you're gonna leave him a tip and
then try to increase his salary to 19
and give you another tip to double it
all right thank you so much
i can raise my heart rate to 90. what's
he doing man
let's do this let's do this
i'm not sure if it's dancing or exercise
right now but i don't know that that
harriet monitor is still at 83. he's not
pushing out enough
thank you so much man thank you
truly appreciate it hello boyfriend wow
someone's singing she's looking for me
i'm looking for you
hi geek culture how are you doing oh my
gosh
have you heard
of
us
have you heard of us
you mean the
you mean the netflix show
there's a netflix show called us right
i'm so embarrassed right now
play an original song for us come on
cheryl
show us what you got 11 years
wow thank you so much thank you so much
for the tape i usually play this song as
my last song it's called if life was
magic and it was written because i
wanted to be a magician in people's
lives to
make um
make people disappear
i hope that there's a little magic in
your life wherever you may be nice being
a musician all right take it away
a little rabbit
picking out from the head
like my problems
i know it would disappear
broken if i first met jacob put on a
show
to put a smile on everyone's face i'll
talk on the ropes and make them they say
so that
should we do it i knows she deserves it
okay
[Music]
what did you do
all right joe i think she deserves a bit
more let's go
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh thank you
yo thank you for the follow gear catcher
tv welcome to brief and thank you so
much
i think his camera needs a bit of help
yeah he needs an upgrade already that's
what the quality you see the quality
here
i don't do 720p now
the reason why i don't have the best
stuff is because i'm not financially
well
i think we can solve that this is the
season of giving
dude you have better webcam i wish man
maybe one day we'll work towards it all
yes right better gear while streaming
thanks for the 10 bucks council tv thank
you thank you so much man see if there's
something that's rewarding enough yeah
does he have the skills
to pay the bills
survive around without using any
abilities and will give you a logitech
stream cam
very focused it's very focused
he's so focused on the game dude thanks
for 20 bucks man how how
how did i do it wait i i i scared i used
my desk
he's going man
game on says
he's the last person
oh no that wasn't me
no
nice number
69
man all right guys if that's a legit
website all my viewers go and check out
that website so
man you guys are freaking awesome man
thank you so much for that good support
i'm looking for something a bit more
different how about art
art yeah oh okay did we came to draw
something yeah have you heard of us geek
culture tv um no i have not heard of
geek culture
should i be hearing about it yes of
course but yeah geek culture what are
you about i'm assuming you're about
geeks
and their culture
come on
let's return the deal yeah let's go
let's go oh sh
geek culture check out our website are
you up for a quick five minutes sketch
challenge
what do you want me to sketch and for
how long five minutes behold your sketch
beholder but make it waifu oh [ __ ] okay
you know what
i'm up for that challenge
you want to make a waifu beholder right
let's uh give like a
loose t-shirt type vibe
carrying a book
oh i'll book worm get it because
worms
on the head
there we go
i'll give it to him i hope you enjoy
that geek culture thank you so much for
the for the donut another 20 dollars
[Music]
culture thank you so much for the tip
huh
i appreciate it maybe you can have me as
a guest on a future stream i don't know
it was great wasn't it yeah pretty good
stuff getting to design our new logo
maybe so we have desiree desiree there's
a really linux let's go desiree yeah
that's a wonderful give a challenge
nothing too hard something pretty easy
are you up for a challenge yeah sure
what's the challenge
what is a brand new yeti x and a
logitech extreme cam sound
wait what for real oh my god this is
going to be fun for their series
challenge she has to make sound effects
throughout the whole round whole round
what the [ __ ] okay i'll try i'll try how
the [ __ ] do you make walking sounds what
the [ __ ] okay
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
i feel like i'm so bad at this challenge
i'm going to get ready
jesus is saving you
here
[Laughter]
oh my god you guys didn't have to holy
thank you so so so much i really
appreciate it i'll use this money and
like um i'll treat my cat to tons of
food all right so we're going to check
out the streamer ben here playing
valerian yeah another valentine
everybody's playing bellarin huh yes
swept campbell's a bit
anything's out of five five dollars
great
i mean gay culture
really that's that's that's it
that's all you're gonna say
maybe you need the right kind of
motivation yeah maybe dude
maybe
okay it was american motivation and
maybe a yeti mic
a yeti might do i i need a new mic no
cap
wow
all right so here's ben's challenge put
his headset on backwards for a round and
win if it's successful we'll give him a
logitech stream cam and a yeti mic
put your headset on full we'll give you
a logitech stream cam
69 we love the
okay just in case you didn't notice this
whole video was brought to you by
logitech right now they have a brand new
stream cam great for streamers that's
why we're on twitch 1080p camera 60 fps
and zeki has the blue gear tx microphone
as well pretty awesome let's go and try
and see how it actually sounds like so
one of my favorite features of the blue
yeti x is of course the blue voice
technology so here we are at the
logitech g hub app and here we can
enable blue voice let's see how we sound
like now
boom
hello mike tess how does this sound
compared to earlier hello ladies and
gentlemen this is the classic radio blue
voice preset the news at 9 00 pm and if
you want to get a little bit more goofy
with your live stream sessions then you
can try the blue voice effects as well
so if you want to sound like a crazy
alien hello
and we can also try the dj robot don't
worry
[Music]
why not try helium chipmunks
[Music]
so yeah plenty of effects and features
with the blue yeti x so do check it out
with that let's go find more streamers
all right
[Music]
looks a bit greeny here
[Music]
okay
debbie i think obviously she sings
pretty well right so why not on purpose
she sings something horribly
okay
good culture
thank you so much for the the tippy your
message says here's to your amazing
singing are you up for challenge
what am i up against come give it to me
give it to me
give us a glimpse of how bad your
singing can go
challenge accepted you want to hear how
terrible singing can be
lie
what song do you want me to sing
terribly to the killers mr bright side
music is my passion
[Music]
control
oh my god
what's our impression you can do
elmo no no but i can do this for you
i bet you can't find anyone else who can
do that ah
it's called
that man
my mind is so blue right now
use your dustbin as a music instrument
and sing the next song
and you get a logitech mic and webcam
i'm so sorry devi but you know
all for
[Music]
this makes me cook on twitch now
can't believe we got her to do that
[Music]
all right
that's 69.
nice yo geek culture thank you so much
for the 69 dollars holy shiny
can we get another shout out to get
culture please and um i'll be awaiting
the logitech mic and webcam wow thank
you thank you thank you
we sent out all the items to all the
streamers let's see how their quality
looks like right now so first we have
the new stream cam that can go up to 60
fps 1080 let's get it you give me a blue
yeti as well
wow
look at this
that guys looks so cool shall we try the
webcam guys
is it clear
whoa
it's so wow
it's so smooth huh
holy
the blue yeti
oh [ __ ]
shout out to geek culture for sending us
all this beautiful and
awesome stuff for improving our it means
better content for you guys thank you
geek culture geek culture reached out to
me and they sent over some logitech
items g915 tkl and it's one of like the
newest versions it's a wireless keyboard
and it's amazing okay so this is what
the keyboard looks like it's amazing
when you download logitech g hub you can
kind of change all the colors and led
lights inside very light minimalistic
and very very pretty okay so this is uh
the yeti mic that they sent over yeah
it's kind of like a little cute little
stand over here it's not too difficult
to use you guys can go for ktv sessions
with this this is like really very good
you guys can do it on discord i'm gonna
change over to uh this yeti mic right
now i'm gonna show you guys what the
logitech stream cam looks like okay are
you guys ready one
two
three
i think this is much better because it's
much lighter it looks less gloomy okay i
look so clear now jesus it scares me and
even uglier than before but it's okay
logitech shrimp camp look at this this
is the newer camp g915
dkl pretty good keyboard it's from
logitech why is this keyboard so light
oh this keyboard is wireless
look at that i can do it market oh
hello my test one two three my test my
test
hello motors hello so i'm trying out a
new camera today my whole setup is
pretty much different today current
camera that i'm using right now is a
logitech stream cam okay of which i'm
actually very happy with um the the
results this is the g915
logitech um wireless keyboard far it's
been very nice i like i like the the
touch of it so of course the next item
right is the headphones the
g733 so it's really cheap okay they're
like really beautiful lights coming up
from the side here it's so lit just look
at it look at it yeah the last thing
that i received is this blue yeti mic
thank you so much again you know to get
culture tv i think you know it was
really a full upgrade from you know all
the products i had before so i would
really like to give another shout out to
get culture tv thank you again so much
for all the products that you've uh so
generously given me all right that's it
for this video i hope you guys enjoyed
it i know i did what about you i'm super
fun psyche and i'm pretty sure that the
streamers had fun too so if you like to
see more videos just like this you guys
know what to do like and subscribe do
share your love and support to the
streamers by checking out the links in
the description below and while you're
down there do check out the logitech
products featured in this video as well
till next time this is zacky i'm gerald
signing off bye bye
[Music]
you